today's video is brought to you by War
Thunder more on them in just a bit
to help smack dab in the middle of the
Old Kingdom period during the fifth
dynasty of Egypt this was an uncertain
time for the ancient civilization there
is no denying that the Great Pyramid
Builders of the fourth Dynasty left
behind an impressive and long-lasting
Legacy which is still admired to this
day but we also can't ignore the fact
that they depleted Egypt's Resources
with their massive construction projects
even during the fourth Dynasty after
Khufu and kafra the pyramids are already
starting to shrink a sign that Egypt
simply did not have the materials in the
workforce to maintain the same Grand
scale Forever This plays the fifth
Dynasty pharaohs in a conundrum you see
pyramids were still very much in Vogue
and no self-respecting Pharaoh would
have been ready to Journey to the other
side of that one on the other hand Stone
didn't grow on trees so the fifth
Dynasty act to compromise and make do
with what they had but that was okay
because the Pharaohs of the fifth
Dynasty had found a new hobby to keep
them busy and that was the worship of RA
the sun god
[Music]
the first pair of the fifth dynasty was
yusukaf who reigned during the early
20th century BC the fifth Dynasty is
when we start to become more informed on
the Pharaohs of Egypt because they began
writing more stuff down but the
information is still severely limited
compared to pharaohs from the later
dynasties for example userkaf's
parentage is Ascension to the throne and
his relationship with the previous King
are all uncertainties tradition portrays
him as part of the same royal family as
the Pharaohs before him perhaps he was
the son of never had a piece the
daughter of pharaoh jadefa there is zero
information on usakat's father but given
Lily came to rule over Egypt it would
not be crazy to assume that the previous
Pharaoh sheep set calf could have been
his father after all they share the same
naming convention and scholars believe
that the transition of power between the
two was peaceful because it seems that
many important administrators from
Shep's fcast time were in office when
usacaf became Pharaoh that does beg the
question though of why exactly usakaf
would trigger the start of a new Dynasty
and not simply continue the previous one
well for that you can blame a scholarly
priest named miniso he was the one who
came up with the dynastic divisions but
he lived thousands of years later during
the third Century BC modern historians
have kept using his system more out of
convenience than accuracy but they are
well aware that sometimes beneath those
separations seemed a bit random such as
in this case if anything the division
might have more to do with usacap's
predecessor than with him since Shep's
eskaf was somewhat of a Maverick who
broke away from the Traditions
established by the previous pharaohs of
his own Dynasty most significantly did
not build a pyramid for himself instead
preferring to go old school and
commission a mastaba which was a smaller
proto-pyramid with a flat roof that the
pharaohs from the first dynasties used
as tombs he also moved away from Geezer
instead building his mastaba at Sakara
which again served as an acropolis for
some of the older pharaohs we don't know
why
did any of this he probably had a good
reason since his fourth dynasty was all
about the pyramids was it simply that
his Nation had been left to impoverished
by his predecessors to afford the
resources for such giant construction
project or was it because the pyramid
was strongly associated with The Cult of
RA or Rey the Sun God and Shep's eskaf
felt that this minor deity was becoming
too powerful ultimately it didn't really
matter since none of his changes stuck
around after he was gone during the
fifth Dynasty it looked like pyramids
and Sun gods were back on the menu and
it all started with yusukaf if the
poorth Dynasty is most notable for the
magnitude of its pyramids then the fifth
one is defined by the worship of RA and
his emergence as the most powerful deity
in the Egyptian Pantheon it seems that
usacap had a short and obscure reign of
only seven to eight years but that time
was enough for him to complete two
important constructions that set the
tone for the Pharaohs who followed him
first up was his own pyramid which he
built at zakara close to the step
pyramid of dejosa from the third Dynasty
the Pyramid of usacaf which nowadays
lies in Ruins was a far cry from the
Grandeur and opulence of the Colossal
structures we see at Giza it was less
than 50 meters tall yet another sign
that the construction projects of Khufu
and his successes forced the fifth
Dynasty pharaohs to temper their
expectations for comparison the Great
Pyramid of Giza was almost 150 meters
tall roughly three times the height of
oosakaft pyramid however it seems that
the mortuary Temple was quite nice with
Rich and elaborate wool relief so it
could be that usacaf simply chose a
quality over quantity approach to his
final resting place or it could be that
he was more interested in building
something else a sun Temple that he
dedicated to ra the practice that would
be repeated by almost all the other
fifth Dynasty Kings thus firmly
establishing ra is the new Hot Shot
among the Egyptian gods also of note was
the fact that the temple was constructed
at abusir a new location that many of
the fifth Dynasty rulers used as the
spot for their Eternal tomb every now
and then pharaohs like to switch up
their burial sites for various reasons
and started a new Metropolis while we
don't know any specific reason why the
fifth Dynasty guys switch from Giza to
Abu Seer it's not that hard to imagine
that they probably did not want their
final resting places to be permanently
overshadowed both figuratively and
literally by the Great Pyramids of the
guys who came before them just before we
continue with today's video I want to
say that it is brought to you by War
Thunder the most comprehensive vehicle
combat game ever made you could play
with more than 2 000 tanks planes
helicopters and ships in Dynamic
combined arms PVP battles there's an
in-depth customization system for
vehicles so you can apply hundreds of
camouflages and markings to your
machines every vehicle's incredibly
detailed and modeled down to all of
their individual Parts offering an
immersive combat experience look as a
fan of History you probably are as well
watching this channel you'll really
enjoy the historical accuracy that War
Thunder has you could play War Thunder
on PC Xbox series X and S PlayStation 5
or the previous console generation it
has incredible graphics and detail and
is in 4k and when you combine this with
the amazing sound effects and music well
it's a great immersive experience so
play War Thunder today and get a large
free Bonus Pack if you register through
MyLink which includes multiple premium
Vehicles premium account boosters and
much more I'll just go to play wt.link
forward slash WT biographics bonus and
now back to today's video
userkaf was followed on the throne by
sahur and once again the circumstances
behind his Ascension remain a mystery
although most scholars believe that sir
was either the son or younger brother of
the previous Pharaoh which is a pretty
safe bet whatever a succession occurs
peacefully from a construction
perspective sir mirrored his predecessor
closely he too built a pyramid and a sun
Temple both at Abu Seer thus abandoning
the old necropolises of Sakara and Giza
completely his pyramid was also of
modest Dimensions even a little smaller
than that of usacaf but once again it
had a snazzy Mortuary Temple so her's
Reign was almost double the length of
USA cap and it seems that he spent a lot
at that time traveling to meet the
neighbors and he sometimes brought his
army along for the ride a military
campaign against Libya is mentioned in
the reliefs of sir's Mortuary Temple as
are several forays into the Sinai
Peninsula Osa her plundered at the local
mines and returned to Egypt with
shipments of copper and turquoise in
order to do this sir had to Vanquish a
new foe one the we had never seen
mention before the meant to ancient
history is full of these small and
obscure kingdoms that never became big
or endearing enough to leave behind
evidence of their existence and today
there simply remembered as names in a
different culture's historical record
there is another one that is mentioned
for the first time during the reign of
sahua the Land of Punt this ancient
kingdom was probably bigger and
certainly more important to the
Egyptians than meant to because it was a
One-Stop shop for mer incense electrum
ebony malachite gold resins and all
other sorts of rare and shiny
Commodities numerous references to
Expeditions too punts were found for
multiple pharaohs going all the way up
to the reign of Hatshepsut during the
New Kingdom a thousand years after
Sahara so it seems that this
civilization stuck around for a good
while given how rich and long-lived it
was it is a little surprising that punt
Left Behind almost no traces of its
existence today archaeologists aren't
even sure of its location although they
believe it was probably somewhere in the
Horn of Africa southeast of Egypt so who
was succeeded by never a care and we
find ourselves in the exact same
situation as before where we're not sure
if the new Pharaoh was the son or the
younger brother of the previous one
although Scholars seemed to lean towards
the latter also like suhur never care
was irresponsible for one pyramid and
one Sun Temple at Abu Seer word on the
street is that his Temple was the
biggest and best of the bunch but it has
yet to be located showing us that
ancient Egypt still has Mysteries that
are waiting to be uncovered the Pyramid
of nephara care is also worth mentioning
it seems that the Pharaoh had regained
some of the ambition and grandiosity
that defied the fourth Dynasty because
he definitely wanted to go out in style
or maybe it was simply a sign that
Egypt's coffers were starting to fill up
once more and the Pharaoh could afford
to splurge again on his final resting
place either way never a cares pyramid
was the biggest thing at abusir in fact
at a height of approximately 72 meters
it would have been taller than the
Pyramid of menkare which is the smallest
of the three main Pyramids of Giza
another unique aspect of nephrase
pyramid was that it started out as a
step pyramid which basically consists of
multiple mastavas of decreasing size
placed on top of the other another
unique aspect of nepherica's pyramid
always that it started out as a step
pyramid which basically consists of
multiple mastabas of decreasing size
placed one on top of the other those had
not been used since the third Dynasty so
perhaps neverakear was the original
hipster who oh and for the Retro look to
be cool the step pyramid was also 20
meters shorter so maybe the Pharaoh saw
that one finished and decided that it
needs to be bigger unfortunately for
never care they ever saw the finished
product he might have had the resources
and the ambition but he didn't have the
health to see the construction to the
end he died after approximately 10-year
reign with his pyramid unfinished but
luckily for him some of his successes
liked him enough to complete his tomb as
far as egyptologists are concerned the
Pyramid of nephara care was one of the
most significant structures of ancient
Egypt not because of its size or how it
was built but because of what they found
inside it the abuse are one of the
largest collections of Old Kingdom
documents in the world most notably they
are the earliest known documents that
were written in erratic script oh we're
sure you've all heard of hieroglyphics
the famously intricate writing system
used in ancient Egypt but that was
actually reserved mainly for formal
documents religious texts wall
inscriptions and things like that nobody
had time to draw birds and eyes of Horus
just a write a receipt or a recipe so
the Egyptians created heratic which was
a simpler and faster cursive script it
was used for almost 2 000 years until it
was replaced by an even simpler script
known as demotic
his contributions to our understanding
of ancient Egypt aside nothing else of
note is known about nephara care but if
it makes you feel any better we know
even less about the two pharaohs who
followed him since they only stuck
around for a cup of coffee before biting
the dust the first ships maybe
egyptologists are actually uncertain
where exactly he fits in the timeline
but after nephrika seems to be the best
bet he wasn't the previous Pharaoh's son
so he most likely was his brother this
means that he was probably pretty old
when he took the throne which could
explain why his Reign only lasted for a
few months as you might imagine Shep's a
care did not get the chance to make much
of an impression it seems like every
Dynasty has at least one guy who
survived as nothing more than a name on
a wall somewhere but we can say about
Shep says care is that he probably
started work on his pyramid there is an
unfinished platform at abusir and by the
process of elimination egyptologists
surmise that it belonged to him however
construction on it only lasted for a few
weeks and unsurprisingly the Pharaohs
who came after him thought no obligation
to continue his work since it meant
almost starting from scratch and they
had their own Immortal Souls to worry
about therefore Shep's care is the only
ruler of the fifth Dynasty without any
kind of Tomb his successor made a
slightly bigger impact but not by much
his name was nefer and there is actually
evidence to suggest that he was the
eldest son of nephara care and his Queen
kenthos II he was around for a couple of
years enough to start work in his
pyramid at Abu sir there is also word
that he built a sun Temple but for the
moment it remains purely hypothetical
either it exists and we haven't found it
yet or it was never finished and
possibly a repurposed by another Pharaoh
as far as his pyramid was concerned only
the first step of nepheffer's tomb was
completed by the time he died again his
successor did not finish it but he did
improvise and turned into a Mustafa so
lefe would at least perhaps something he
also completed the mortuary Temple so
obviously the next Pharaoh felt some
kind of Duty towards him that's not
surprising given that the historical
records suggests that the next Pharaoh
was never a Fair's younger brother his
name was nussier and he would go on to
have the longest Reign so far serving as
Pharaoh for at least two and a half
decades this gave him enough time to
work not only on his own building plans
but also to finish or renovate a few
projects from earlier pharaohs such as
the solar Temple of usakaf nafra's
aforementioned Mortuary Temple the
Pyramid of nephara care who by most
accounts would have been nusair's father
and even the valley Temple of mancaro
from the fourth Dynasty as far as his
own constructions were concerned nusa
followed the traditional fifth Dynasty
Formula One Sun temple one pyramid at
Abu Seer plus the extra DLC stuff
Mortuary Temple Queens Pyramid Valley
Temple Etc strangely enough his own
pyramid was on the smaller size even
though he had plenty of time to make it
as big as he wanted even in His Glory
Days it Rose to just slightly above 50
meters this was probably due to the
pyramid's odd location all of the
previous ones were situated on the same
axis with plenty of space between them
but nusa chose to squeeze his pyramid
between those of sahua and his father
this allowed him to do a clever bit of
recycling by taking the unfinished
Causeway and Valley tamball that reached
the Gnar river which originally were
intended for his father's pyramid and
divert them to his own thus saving a
fair bit on materials and labor maybe
nusair was just practical and Frugal or
maybe this was a sign that Egypt was
still hurting financially following the
exorbitant excesses of the fourth
Dynasty or maybe nusair simply banned on
the priorities his pyramid might not
have been anything to inscribe how I'm
about but his Sun Temple was a different
matter he built it at Abu garab a short
distance from Abu sir and made it
entirely of stone which was a costly
Endeavor but it ensured that the Winds
of time would not be able to huff and
puff and blow it down as easily as the
others that included a giant Obelisk and
a boat replica also made of stone which
might have had some kind of symbolic or
ceremonial significance it's fair to say
that new was the most prolific builder
of the fifth Dynasty despite the long
length of his Reign he spent most of his
time on construction projects and
renovation projects so he really didn't
have much time for anything else
we're going to venture into Mercury
Waters following the death of no sir his
successor is very poorly attested in the
historical record and the few things
that we do know about him only make him
more mysterious for starters you'll
notice that his name does not end in r e
in reference to the sun god a Divergence
from all other fifth Dynasty pharaohs
except for usacaf does this mean that
menkahor wasn't a raw devotee well maybe
and maybe not since ancient texts say
that he still built a temple to worship
the Sun God if it exists it has yet to
be found because menkahor chose to
abandon Abu Seer we don't know what
prompted this move but Nisar was the
last ruler to be buried there because
the Pharaohs who followed him decided to
pack up and go back to Sakara menka Hall
built his pyramid at Sakara as well at
least that's what we assume its location
is also up in the air a bit and it
wasn't until 2008 that some ruins known
as The Headless pyramid were attentively
identified as belonging to the Pharaoh
although it is not exactly a settled
matter yet hope that had a short reign
of eight to nine years but his successor
went in the complete opposite direction
and enjoyed the longest reign of the
fifth Dynasty possibly even exceeding 40
years According to some King lists his
name was jedkarer and although he is
well attested in the historical record
his relationships with his predecessors
and his successor are unspecified
Scholars usually take the safe approach
and assume that he was the son or
younger brother of the guy who came
before him since there's no side of him
being usurped just like menkahor jitkara
began to stray from the Traditions
established by the other fairies of the
fifth Dynasty for starters he did not
build a sun Temple at all and this
wasn't due to a lack of time or
resources he chose not to do it perhaps
a sign that the worship of RA had fallen
out of fashion with the new pharaohs he
also favored Sakara over abhishir as the
location for his pyramid jakara
constructed his final resting place
close to Shep says Cather final Pharaoh
the fourth Dynasty who if you'll recall
was himself a bit of a rebel who didn't
like to follow tradition and was not a
card carrying member of The Cult of
Wrath and Club maybe jitkara
purposefully did this to align himself
with Shep's calf or perhaps he just
liked the location jakarib certainly
wasn't hostile towards the earlier
fairies of the fifth Dynasty according
to inscriptions he even helped to
restore some of their funerary temples
at abuse here that were looking a little
run down and that collection of
ultra-important papiri written in her
attic script that was found inside the
funeral complex of neverakear it was
dated to jedkara's Reign so he
definitely did not abandon abisir
completely given his long range Hikari
had time to extend his administrative
interests to areas other than the
Journey of his Eternal Soul he enacted
reforms that led to a rebalancing of
power for both priests and state
officials many lower officials lost some
of their Authority while high-ranking
bureaucrats such as viziers even got
their own pyramids or mastabas although
on a much smaller scale of course it was
probably the first time in Egypt that we
saw evidence of an effort to
decentralize power and spread the
authority around a bit instead of
placing it all on the shoulders of one
guy unfortunately what exactly motivated
jedkara to take such actions remained a
mystery was he somehow coerced into
doing so was he manipulated by clever
this years or did he do it of his own
free will when jakara died sometime
during the mid-24th century BC he was
succeeded by unas the last pair of the
fifth Dynasty even though he is also
credited with a long Reign that spanned
several decades there is not much to
note about him it seems that the fifth
Dynasty ended up with a bang but with a
whimper once again erasing the question
if there was any valid reason to create
separation between the fifth and sixth
dynasties instead of merging them
together anyway the most noteworthy
thing about inas was unsurprisingly his
pyramid like his predecessor he stayed
at Sakara and completely skipped over
the sun Temple at an original height of
approximately 43 meters the Pyramid of
unas was the smallest of all the fifth
Dynasty pyramids the ones that were
finished we mean even so the structure
ranks highly with archaeologists because
inside it they found the pyramid texts a
collection of funery writings there
represent the oldest Egyptian religious
texts ever found and among the oldest in
the entire world outside of the pyramid
unas built tombs for two of his queens
nebet and kenut this was quite common as
many other pyramids came with miniature
versions of themselves for the queens of
the pharise but an ass chose to bury his
queens and bastard as instead of tiny
pyramids this is more of a curiosity
than anything with a deep meaning the
Pharaoh probably did this due to a lack
of resources hence why's own pyramid was
so diminutive in stature but it did make
bunass the first to employ the pyramid
Mustafa combo the end of his Reign then
the ending of his dynasty for that
matter came with the same kind of
uncertainty as all the other successions
so far maybe moneto knew something we
don't and he had a good reason to close
the pith Dynasty following the death of
inas maybe the Pharaoh died without an
heir and this led to a succession crisis
this is certainly a possibility that
egyptologists have considered although
it remains at the moment more of an idea
than a proven Theory even so we will
stick with the general consensus and
bring our coverage of the fifth Dynasty
to an end until we resume with the sixth
Dynasty which represented the end of the
first golden age of Egypt known as the
Old Kingdom
just before we end today's video thank
you again to War Thunder sponsoring it
get a large free Bonus Pack if you
register through my link below which
includes multiple premium Vehicles
premium account boosters and much more
or just go to play WT dot link forward
slash WT biographics bonus and thank you
for watching